hello today we are going to look in on
the African night crawlers and I'm going
to discuss the 10 things that I learned
last year that uh probably I will not
repeat in the future
so as we're going through here you can
see I've got a
nice crop of really nice huge African
night crawlers here
um who don't want to be cute for the
camera
but what we're going to do is we're
going to kind of go through things here
and uh while I'm talking I'll just you
know Yammer on so I would say the number
one thing that I learned this year is
that
um too many worm bins
at one point in time I think I had
something like 23 worm bins
and quite honestly that is too much I uh
that's you know more than I can
comfortably take care of
um in a week or what have you so you may
have noticed that I have started
limiting my bins and that I am slowly
you know getting things down these are
not worms these are pieces of bonsai
um slowly started reducing the number of
bins
uh just to make it a little bit easier
for myself it was getting just a little
bit too crazy
so I have been coming in and adding
about a gallon of water a week
and um
it still looks like it could totally use
some more so we will add more at the end
here
just going to keep going through to see
if there's any food or Bedding left and
it looks like they've taken you know and
eaten everything that I've given them
it's a little hard to tell if they've
eaten the um
manure but uh from the looks of it
uh yeah I can't tell
if anybody knows how to tell the
difference between worm castings and uh
manure let me know
so I would say the second thing is that
um worms can eat meat and that was not
in this bin it was in a mixed species
bin worms can eat meat however
uh in the process of eating all that
meat they did attract a crap ton of
flies I will put an insert of pictures
and I would say after two months of not
feeding meat to that bin I am still
struggling to get all of the flies out
of the basement and if I was to ever do
it again I'm telling you I would only do
it in a super deep bin
and I would bury that meat very very
deep
um
yeah so I I have proof of concept but
I'm not going to say that that is
something that I would do
um frequently
you know at all
all right so number three
um I think I've gone out of my way to
not spend a lot of money on my worm bin
but then I go back and I spend money on
the garden in the way of coconut choir
perlite soil amendments
and it just hit me if you saw my most
recent video about uh ways to help your
garden
um I will link that video at the end but
basically what I've started doing is
I've started adding some of my soil
amendments that are organic that are
going to take months and months to break
down
and I'm adding them to the worm bedding
and that way the worm bends
can uh work over all of that stuff and
then it'll actually be ready by the time
my garden needs it you know three or
four months from now
so I am spending more money on the worms
than I used to I'm still you know
recycling all of my shipping boxes by
feeding them to the worms but I have
started adding you know some more things
that I don't normally do in the way of
like azomite and things like that but if
you add them to the worm bin then you
don't need to really add as much to the
Garden later so I am spending more money
but hopefully saving money later so
number four
um one of the only bins that was
actually
uh impacted by my my trip my faded trip
was that these African night crawlers
and I purchased more because I lost you
know most of my African night crawlers
and what I've discovered is that worms
can go a very long time without having
new food but what they cannot do without
is moisture and uh our house sitter you
know was kind of on the bubble as to
whether or not they wanted to
you know manage any worms so I was like
no no no you don't have to mess with the
worms
um
so that was part of the deal and then
when we got stuck over there there
wasn't anybody to come in and actually
take care of the African night crawlers
uh when they needed moisture and so I
did have quite the die off so they can
go without food no problem moisture
that's the deal breaker that they cannot
do without
so now that we've gone through all of
this I'm gonna looks like we might have
to harvest this the next time we're
getting pretty full
yeah there's really nothing left
okay so the sixth thing is that slow
food fast food might actually have more
to do with the chemical makeup of the
food than it has to do with the Frozen
not frozen fibrous not fibrous and
things like that in my bin I have
experienced the slowest food it was
being cranberries which you would think
are soft and Squishy nope uh 10 months
Ginger even pre-frozen nine months
pineapple even though it was frozen it
took six months and then of course
apples something that everybody feeds
their bin take about four months even if
they're frozen for the worms to eat them
all
okay I'm gonna give them some paper
bedding
this is my normal prepared bedding
that's been sitting here for a couple of
months
um then I'm going to add some of the
manure here the seventh thing that
basically I found out grit may not be
necessary but it might just slow down
how fast the worms are able to consume
the food the bin that I had no grit in
seemed to thrive quite well but I didn't
have a twin bin and so maybe it could
have done better I don't know but uh the
no grit worked but you know was it the
best choice not really because I do add
grit to the rest of my worm bins
okay so that's about a gallon of the uh
composted cow manure
I'm gonna put that over here on this
side
and uh for the eighth thing that I
really kind of came to the conclusion is
that me having a worm channel has made
me a better worm farmer everybody who
watches is not newbies I have a lot of
people who have maybe even three four
five times more experience with worms
than I do
and I just have this channel to kind of
document my process in becoming a worm
farmer and it's really really helpful
that people do comment and give me ideas
like hey maybe this is your problem or
maybe you could do this or I've had good
luck with this and honestly it's made me
a much better worm farmer with you know
without that feedback I probably would
be
not as good as I am today
okay next we're gonna get some of my
worm Chow
I'm probably gonna give them about two
cups here
kind of scruff it in with the
the top of the
the bedding the paper bedding here
I can put up on the screen what this is
made out of
and one of the other things that I've
discovered number nine is that there's
not just one way to be successful in
your worm farming there are no absolutes
um there are too many variables for you
to say absolutely this has to happen my
African night crawlers have to be in a
vermi bag or a urban worm bag or
something similar because they escape I
live on a busy road the vibrations drive
them a bit nuts and so without that my
African night crawlers would be all over
the floor and would be worm jerky we
know people that are on my Channel or
have other channels that just have uh
African nightcrawlers in open bins and
they're perfectly fine they don't try
and Escape
uh you know I think it's the vibrations
that are doing it in my case but there's
no perfect way to do a worm bin and so I
have learned that there are many ways to
be successful and there are also many
ways to fail
okay so let's get them a little bit of
water
I'm gonna put that right along the edge
where the
um heating pad is it seems that I'm
holding moisture really well every place
else in the bin
except for there
but I am going to give them a little bit
all the way around
we're kind of having a warm spell again
so you never know what's going to happen
okay and so then oops
I'm also going to give them some
vegetables
they haven't had any in a while and you
know
variety is the spice of life I wouldn't
want them to uh get bored
my potatoes are starting to chit already
I might have a problem there
but there's you know
probably five pounds of African night
crawlers in here and I look in on this
bin and feed them actual food
about once a month even though I do come
in here and uh
give them
worm Chow every single week and then the
10th thing that I have learned is that
having a full-time job and a channel is
very hard but it is totally worth it
when my day job is driving me nuts and
it does
um I can come home change gears and hang
out with you guys and my worms and
everything seems a little bit brighter
and a little bit better
so if you liked the video about my
African nightcrawlers I have a playlist
for all of the African nightcrawlers
right over here and if you've seen that
YouTube thinks you're gonna like this
video over here so if you like the video
give it a muddy thumbs up if you're not
a member of my worm family click that
subscribe button and if you want to know
what I'm doing when I'm doing it ring
that Bell icon alright guys thanks for
hanging out with me and my worms and
everybody have a good day
thank you
foreign